not a normal a normal dick would go
all right all right right
normal normal dicks use less words to
get the [ __ ] because that's right you
know what that is that's actually ass
burger dick yeah that's what I'm
thinking ass dick
[Music]
this is one of my favorite articles this
is probably gonna be the The Daily
Double JK News Daily devil
because when I saw this I love the daily
Devils when I saw this headline I was
like holy [ __ ]
it's so good this is so good are you
ready all right from Insider they say
all those new servers at your favorite
restaurant aren't just bad at waiting
tables they might wind up crashing the
entire economy what
some of these new waiters dude not that
good they're economy crashes huh economy
that's right well um yeah they're gonna
blame everything that's going on with
the economy on these servers so how do
they have all the leverage man I need
more information what's the article
saying so they're saying that labor
productivity is measured as a total
output per hour worked but there's much
more to it than that if you pop the hood
the measure also accounts for things
like compensation of the workers
of the workforce workers ages education
as well as changes in the quality of
Machinery Tech and Facilities that
workers have to use so that they they're
measuring total Factor productivity
and they're adding it all up to say that
productivity helps us Define how
efficient a society how efficiently a
society uses its resources
signal of how quickly an economy will
grow long term
is it pretty good now
and they're basing all of this off of
Applebee's that's all I was gonna say
they're basically saying that
productivity the the there's a
sluggishness to productivity compared to
previous recoveries so usually like you
would see
um productivity increasing and not kind
of tapering off which is what we're
seeing right now and that's because
waiters are not objectively better than
the last waiters of generation prior
it's because they're people got too much
money from the stimulus so they don't
have to to work so all these all these
waiters were coming in they're all like
young kids and [ __ ] who need to work
because they didn't get no stimmies and
so now we're getting [ __ ] [ __ ]
service and we're probably gonna [ __ ]
these guys are gonna crash the economy
makes sense because we're paying a
premium for them
uh no because because we're paying for
them at all oh so the okay so the
productivity output from the your
average waiter does not justify what
they're receiving in conversation that's
right that's kind of a big ass slap in
the face that's kind of what was amazing
about this headline is that like all at
the same type of culmination of things
like inflation plus like higher wages
plus like uh The Stereotype or the
social like uh Norm for tipping a
suddenly like automatic 18 minimum like
you know what I mean are there all these
fat
to wake the room up let me tell you
about Capital deepening
Capital deepening is winning is when
Investments I like that too robots
software Machinery Rises more quickly
than hours of Labor worked
uh thank you for saying that it makes
sense so from 1990 to 2010 Capital
deepening was an important driver of
strong productivity growth but it
stalled for nearly a decade following
the financial crisis but by 2016 things
started to turn around Capital deepening
uh fall asleep all right I hear you guys
shouldn't we recover fat
Amazon as like
the digital Costco because things are so
fast because of like Automation and all
that stuff like purchases should be like
at a higher rate yeah it's Instant
versus at Costco you still got to go
find the thing or whatever the thing and
go check out versus Amazon it's like
[ __ ] shampoo food [ __ ] chips and
the robot goes and gets it yeah inside
your house have you noticed as an
employer more people dropping off of
your employee roles like more people
quitting
um we're in a unique space a lot of
people quit here huh yeah
goddamn right in in Fitness real quick
Fitness it's a little bit different I
think because people are in it for a
passion so I think if you have like more
of the regular College type job like you
work at like a Starbucks or something
like that where most people work at
Starbucks where they call those
transitionary jobs or something not like
yeah they're not aspiring Baristas you
know they're just like oh we got I need
to make some money as I'm going through
college like we all did I think that's a
little bit different yeah they're always
hiring it's not adding any value to your
life well employers are noticing that
many workers don't know how to do their
jobs very efficiently right now like I
was mentioning earlier right but then
there's also too much churn in the job
market like workers are going to find a
job that suits them better they're going
to get paid a bit more for that and
everyone wins but right now we have too
much of a good thing is what they're
saying the quit weight uh the quit rate
remains higher than it's ever been when
a worker quits one job starts a new one
it takes time for them to learn the
ropes so there's more people on the job
who just don't know what's going on yet
and so you're noticing maybe where you
are the waiters like bringing you chili
and you ask for soup they don't even
know what they don't even know what that
is yet they're gonna [ __ ] crash the
economy with that [ __ ] I'm telling you
dude [ __ ] [ __ ] dude right like
you're like oh I asked for a fork right
and they brought you a spoon because
they're they're new have you seen those
automatic Jamba Juice places no way no
what you just like I mean bam all the
fruit you can see all the fruit in these
different compartments and then when you
order your drink you see it all it'll
like make this
so what's the solution you're just
Innovative out of a job yeah you
complain then you just you're out of
existence yeah yeah dude there's these
security things at the casinos now have
you seen these Bart where they have like
this [ __ ] like it looks like a dome
and it's just it's called a security
robot I'm not kidding it sounds like a
joke but it's like just going around
like this and it has [ __ ] cameras on
it and honestly I think that that
probably is better than a security guard
that's not gonna do [ __ ] anyway if I
like [ __ ] grab money and leave
they're not gonna do anything about it
yeah at least the security bot gots has
footage of them they probably follow you
out or something yeah innovate it out of
a job I'm telling you but then there is
the job of like now they need attack to
[ __ ] refill to fix your [ __ ] so now
you have to higher paying jobs and then
you need somebody to make that text
outfit in their patch
and then back in the Barista now there's
more space who makes lunch for the Lunch
Makers
themselves
I thought this was going to patreon I
was like what the [ __ ] because I'm at my
barber and I'm like who cuts your hair
and he goes
yeah usually it's like the people in
there cut each other's hair huh right
makes sense and he's like so what was
that business idea that you had you're
like never mind
nothing nothing yeah yeah it was uh it
was a fleeting fun do you guys still
feel like because I remember right when
things started opening up I know I had
this thought and we've talked about it
here but you would see service industry
wise like
things kind of took a hit like it's not
as fast it's [ __ ] up right now yeah
crazy things take a little long yeah
what's good service
bro Jenny's is like packed now I saw
Denny's I was at I was just driving by I
thought Danny's at like 10 30 it's like
packed outside the [ __ ] thing hey
IHOP be always packed though I have
yours back but not Denny's there's a
labor shortage across the board in every
single industry it's even in like
hospitals like a couple people that work
in hospitals and they're like dude we've
hired so many people but they don't know
what they're doing they're not qualified
to work that's a place that shouldn't
happen why they why'd they hire them
then well because you that's when it's
like then you think about it like oh the
manager's not really that good at
figuring out what they need for this
role in this position and there's all
those stupid tick tocks that are like if
you've been at the same place three
years what do you do with your life you
got people just [ __ ] quitting and
moving around and then you know it's
like it's just crazy it feels like the
entire nation is just shuffling cards
right now so there's like literally no
stability yeah it's like everyone's just
being shuffled from here left to right
it's crazy and nobody wants those jobs
hey you remember though like a couple
weeks ago or whatever I don't know if we
did the article there was that one dude
who had been working at like Burger King
or something oh yeah 30 years right
that's all rare now exactly but then to
honor him they gave him like nothing
why would people be incentivized to be
like yeah I just got trained here let me
stay here for a long time you company
man you big boy what'd you get for it
dude yeah there's no climbing the
ladders through like hard work anymore
you know what I mean it's just like you
there's always like these quick get in
type things and you're like seeing
everybody you're just consuming how
everybody else got like super successful
really really fast yeah so you just keep
on trying to like re-shuffle that deck
of cards for yourself too and I think
it's just a time frame for all of us and
there's a ceiling right so like if you
have worked at Burger King for 30 years
I assume you can make a Whopper faster
than a new guy but how much faster right
there's the ceiling on that Burger King
doesn't give a flying [ __ ] if you're
making it two seconds faster if they can
save some money and your pay is not
gonna reflect that yeah attacks you
first
can I ask us can I ask a really strange
question no So like um you know how
employers have to be all inclusive to
you know anybody who wants to work there
if somebody had Asperger's and they're
like hey I want to work at this like
bubble place then they have to hire them
and they don't have to disclose that
they have Asperger's right yeah um so if
they're just kind of being a kind of a
dick to you and it's not because they're
a dick but that's just their condition
yeah are you allowed to complain in that
situation yeah I think it depends on the
sport okay you don't know because you
don't know if you're if you're well one
because there have been some times that
I had a person that I'm like I could
swear you have like a something's what's
his name what's his name in quest but if
you saw him and you realized like oh
this guy might be a little off would you
complain about that well that's the
thing is I don't know if
I'm the dick for coming I don't think
you would complain about that you know
what I'm gonna do because it's not his
fault if this dude has Asperger's and
he's like passive aggressive with
everything he says and he can't read
social cues that's not his fault yet if
he's in that job because it's like oh
we're not gonna not hire you because of
that yeah but it's still like a service
industry on the flip side if Joe's the
one doing the hiring he's going to go
outside in the waiting room which one of
you guys got Asperger's all right you
three the four on the line
and he'll literally hire those guys just
because they have it in the future if
I'm so what you're saying is they're
going to the wrong places you gotta yes
like-minded people you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah like-minded is a good way to
use aspers by the way if I'm in an
altercation with somebody in the future
and they're being angry with me I'm
gonna be like you know what sir I'm just
gonna assume that you have Asperger's
hope you have a nice day and he's like
wow thank you that's like a great way to
it yeah I mean because like I I feel bad
because like yeah I thought you're gonna
go the other way somebody's being angry
you're like excuse me sir I have
Aspergers oh I'm so sorry there was that
really funny Larry David Kirby
Enthusiasm episode he was being a dick
to everybody and he just told him like
oh I'm on the Spectrum they're like oh
I'm so sorry oh you're autistic I'm
sorry how many people do you think are
gonna use that as an excuse and get away
with it and get away with it isn't
everyone Identify some [ __ ] like oh my
God I'm [ __ ] my my Mars this my
[ __ ] Capricorn whatever and because
of that you have to like I have covet
again a person with Asperger's is like
what people use all the time that I'm
getting a little annoyed about is like
anxiety oh yeah just like yeah dude we
all have anxiety all the time everyone
is pushing it down behind a [ __ ]
whole list of labels now and it's like
hey you're not dealing with meat you're
dealing with this yeah okay so you
better accept all this first so [ __ ]
yourself push it down swallow it the
more I'm starting to feel uh certain
anxiety that I didn't have before yeah
like when I go to like Costco and it's
like really really busy Sunday of course
I I didn't realize I could get that like
[ __ ] weirded out don't do any [ __ ]
Asian moms here but that's why you go at
9am when they open so you don't get
anxious with all these [ __ ] people at
Costco and they don't have samples out
yet but you're right so then you got it
then you gotta yeah how could you even
suggest that Blast for me right now come
on man you gotta take the hit that now
we also know you're either a senior
citizen or have a business account at
Costco 9 A.M guy oh my God Black Card my
personal trainer
I need the waters everyone's there and
all the carts are [ __ ] double wide so
like it's just a completely [ __ ]
situation and nobody's ever paying
attention when they're walking see it's
not I'm not hiding behind anxiety it's
just Costco but you also trade with it
you know you just go in and you
experience it and like let's say you act
out online you don't [ __ ] go well
excuse me you should have known this
reputation right that's true people like
this is kind of like a nice thing people
use it no no you're awesome you don't do
people use it as like their Shield yeah
like don't you know I got ADHD how dare
you
you're like I didn't even know you
existed until I turned the corner on the
bakery section is that a bad thing to
like wonder if there would be a some
type of visual cue that will let you
know somebody has if somebody has one of
those [ __ ] dogs with a little like
red thing around it I'm like great great
you're [ __ ] blind yeah God you're
such a nuisance like there should be
like a universal like sign language
thing that like less people like
Asperger's people like this now like got
it because that would be the I think
that would be one of the worst things is
like because there's this [ __ ] guy
I'll just tell you works at [ __ ]
tiger sugar in little toky or whatever
tiger sugar he's a [ __ ] dick yeah I
like tiger sugar I know me too but when
this guy's working you you swear that
like something's wrong with him like
he's super just like gotta stick all the
way up his ass yeah probably does and he
does and you just can't you can't wrap
your head around it and and at one point
I was like I just want to [ __ ] take
this whole everything in this room and
just Chuck it at him but then I was like
how [ __ ] terrible would that be if he
had some kind of mental thing yeah and
then I'm the crazy guy but he's still
just a dick too I think both could be I
think he's just a dick but then you
can't it's it's a dick at such a degree
that you're like no way he's gonna be
clinical something has to be he's
clinically a [ __ ] dick yeah he's
trying to give us like an example of
okay try to order a drink okay
um can I have the number three drinks I
don't know I'm sorry you're confusing me
because you said number three but you
were pointing at number two from the
trajectory that you were standing so I
need to know right away which one you're
talking about yeah that's Aspergers
thank you that's also a dick that's not
a normal a normal dick would go
normal dicks use less words to get the
[ __ ] because that's right you know
what that is that's actually ass burger
dick yeah that's what I'm thinking last
dick because if you're Asperger helpful
you'll be like order the drink and play
number three
man you order the three but actually
pointed at the two
because then you're helpful you still
have Asperger's you can't help the
Asperger freeze freeze oh [ __ ]
freeze
but he's asked for this dick
foreign